hey wassup guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to the next episode of the
Civilization series so last time we went
over the all the different things that
we needed to write our floats doubles
and bullying's okay and we also covered
some pretty cool stuff about bit fills
and how we can actually combine multiple
bullying's into a single bite because of
course they do when they take up one bit
of actual data anyway today what we're
going to do is we're going to kind of
wrap off this civilization rider class
because we've it's looking pretty good
right now there are very very few things
missing but essentially we want to be
able to write out strings somehow and
then also stuff like just fight arrays
and arrays in general okay those are the
kind of things that we kind of want the
ability to write out so strings okay
strings are generally pretty easy to
write the reason strings and we've
actually done that kind of once if you
actually scroll to the top here you'll
see that RC get bytes we kind of did
actually use a string then we used to
get by its method here through
essentially return ourselves a byte
array okay
so that's basically the idea behind
writing strings yeah it's pretty simple
okay however that's not really the
proper way to do that unless you really
know what the length is when we write
this out this will be two bytes okay and
that's fine that's totally okay because
we know it's going to be two bytes
because it's our header and we know what
they and we know that we're gonna have
like a two byte identifiers at the
beginning about file format that's fine
but however we don't normally know how
long a string is right you can't just be
like okay all strings are you know eight
characters long as I mean it doesn't
make any sense right so what we need to
do is somehow have we need we know
somehow we need to somehow encode into
this string how long it actually is so
that we can retrieve the right number of
characters because you know we could
just keep going if we don't know how
long the string is we can just kind of
keep reading and never hit the end until
we don't know until we run out of the
file like literally okay so we need a
way to be able to say that okay the
string is this long and to read this
this many bytes into a string
and that's all I need to okay so that's
what we're gonna cover today and we're
also going to hopefully have enough time
to cover the reverse of this so we've
gone from how to go from values such as
floats Long's the integers all these
types into by arrays but what about the
reverse how do we actually basically go
from having a byte array back into a
float and all of that stuff as well
because of course writing is nice but we
need to also do the reverse of that
which is reading so so strings write
really easy to do let's just kind of
write what we want to do we've got a
string here called name name will be
churner
and then we basically want to do
something like we did before which is
just pointer let's just make this like a
bit longer might make it know we can
just get rid of this stuff so we'll
maybe keep the the two bullets there
just for fun but we will get rid of the
long okay so we've got plenty of space
left we just want to kind of do right by
its data pointer and name okay so how do
we write that string out well what we'll
do is we'll actually make a special
method out of this that actually writes
the length as well so what we can do
here is we'll make a method called write
bytes of course we'll have a destination
the pointer and then the actual string
so string string and we've got we've
actually got a few options here okay we
could do one of two things and we could
also do both of them okay the first
thing we could do is simply write the
size before the string okay that's
pretty simple so in other words if we
literally had letters Cherno before that
we might arrive something like six okay
and then maybe you know typically one by
probably isn't enough because that
really only limits us to 255 characters
of the string if that was an unsigned
byte so usually you might have a shot
okay so in this case that short might be
0 6 and then we have like so that's 2
bytes of course and then we have 1 by 4
H
character or something like that all
right and if we were to group this into
bytes then it would look something like
that okay we could do that that's pretty
popular I actually like doing it that
way and then we obviously know that when
we read this we know that the next six
bytes one two three four five six will
be our entire string okay the other
thing we could do is actually have a
null termination character okay what
this means is that at the end of our
string we simply have a zero okay and a
zero means that we've reached the end of
our string okay now this is literally
going to be like a zero in like binary
okay this is very different than the
actual character zero which has a
completely different number or a
completely different byte representation
right it's not just it's not just zero
right so there you go and also I was
kind of writing this is one thing I want
to I want you guys to notice that I was
kind of writing this into byte chunks
which probably wasn't correct because
this might you might be confusing as
with hexadecimal or whatnot obviously in
my representation here for example this
was kind of taking up work as well but I
would kind of instead of being like
instead of taking up you know four bits
I was kind of taking out one by two
digit here um thing okay instead of four
bits so don't confuse that with hex or
anything but um anyway that being said
that's what you could do okay so you
would have essentially a single byte
termination character at the end of that
okay and there you go you're done you
could also have both almost like as a
safety precaution so in this case you
could have something like 0 6 then
churner and then a null termination
character at the end as well that's fine
okay and that's that's it so we're going
to actually go with the first option
just because I prefer the first option I
think it's a good idea it's yeah
I just I like the idea of knowing how
long the string is before we read it
because if you go with this option then
you obviously just kind of keep reading
the string until you reach that in all
terminator
character or it's kind of called a null
and a termination character because it
is a termination character and the value
of the termination character is null
zero meaning that it's it's you know the
string has been terminated terminated
but anyway that's kind of the way that
we can do this so we're going to choose
the first option so to do that we need
first of all rise out a short of length
the string so we'll say we'll just do
right
all there pointer equals right bytes
it's going to be the destination of
course the pointer and the value here
will be casted to a short the length of
the string so just string that length
okay
so that that's that written out and then
finally we need to simply write out the
byte array so what one of the things
that we don't have here which I'm going
to actually have in a minute here is the
ability to write out just a byte array
okay so we need to essentially have like
a bit of a mem copy so that we can copy
anything in a source byte array into
this destination byte array okay so
let's write that quickly because I'm
actually surprised we don't have that
we'll put it at the very top or in fact
maybe after this byte maybe not
that's very tough public static int
right bytes so this will be destination
in pointer and then source as well this
is very similar to the kind of C style
mem copy I accept you know the
parameters are a bit different but
anyway the idea here is that will simply
do something like for int I equals 0 or
rather we can just do something like for
int I equals I will do 0 is less than
source dot length I plus plus and then
will simply do something like a
destination point I plus plus equals
source I okay and then we'll return
pointer
so very very simple it just literally
will go through everything copy you
might you could use something called
system array copy which takes in the
source which in this case would be sorry
source source position which would be 0
destination destination position which
would be pointer and length which would
be sourced or length and you could do
that that's actually closer to kind of
firm copy and that probably is a mem
copy to be honest it's a native function
it's probably resolves to an mm copy but
mmm we're just gonna do it this way
because it's yeah it'll probably get I
imagine this will get compiled into
something that is a mem copy but I again
I have no idea how the Java Virtual
Machine works under the hood it's
obviously a lot more complicated than
something like native code but anyway
it'll be fine for our purposes at least
so in fact if you guys want to do some
benchmarks and figure out what's faster
that's fine for me these these
benchmarks have always ended up being
virtual machine implementation-specific
so different platforms will yield
different results so different versions
of Java will behave differently it's
just a bit of a nightmare
really so I feel free though too
I've shown you both ways to do something
as simple as that and you can do it any
way you like
so return right by its destination
pointer and of course string dot get
bytes okay sweet so there we go
and if we want to verify something like
that I'm actually going to just clear
like all of this because I don't really
want it to get in the way here but we'll
just do something like right bytes data
zero a name and then we'll print bytes
and we'll see what we actually get so
first of all that should take up around
well I would imagine this would take up
eight bytes but we've got sixteen here
so let's kind of just let's put it to
eight or nine in fact and we'll see what
happens okay so we've got the six okay
of course it's a short which is why the
first one you see here is zero but that
number is six just like I kind of led
out there and then we've got these bytes
that make our paterno hopefully I'm
verify it but it will seem like 43 seems
about right since we know that the the
letter a capital letter a is 41 in
hexadecimal but anyway and you can you
can look up some kind of ASCII chart or
whatever you want to figure out exactly
what it is but there we have it okay
1 2 3 4 5 6 bytes which make up the word
chana here and of course the 0 is just
the last fight if we get rid of that
okay so we know immediately that we have
6 bytes to read and the following by
side of light so that we want to read
okay awesome so there's the string now
let's make the reverse of all these okay
a lot of them are going to be pretty
simple such as for example like this
byte situation here is kind of going to
be exactly the same because we can just
kind of look up the battery and look at
one particular index and that byte array
and that will actually be that byte so
there might not even be need I need to
do something like that but we'll
probably write functions for this anyway
so public static int read int now we'll
have to obviously name them separate
things because we can't distinguish
methods by return type alone but we'll
start with int why not so we'll have the
source we'll have the pointer and that's
it
okay so that's all we need a source and
a pointer so to read an int okay this is
where the fun begins all we really have
to do is read four bytes from this
source at index pointer okay and then
all them together to make that integer
so if we had an integer in in binary
let's just say it was number let's just
say I don't know what this is gonna be
obviously but let's just say that in hex
our representation looks something like
this okay what we want to do is we want
to take all of these separate bytes and
essentially combine them into a single
integer or a single kind of 32 by 32
that is a bit kind of value obviously in
memory and whatnot these are going to
say the same okay well in this case
we'll actually copy them but the point
is that they'll stay the same so it's
it's we're just kind of telling Java hey
this is how our
this is what our byte array means is
these are what these four bytes mean
they are an integer I'm telling you
they're an integer and you're gonna have
to trust me on that
okay they could be a flow obviously they
could be anything we don't know what
they are okay
it's up to our format to tell us what
types a time we're gonna talk about
types and whatnot next next video but
essentially again in something like C++
it would be simple it would be as simple
as doing something called a type Pond
okay or type punning which means that we
basically tell the compiler hey the
memory that the rather the data or this
memory address is an integer okay and
we're done essentially because it types
an all real thing right if you look at
memory it's just a bunch of bytes and
it's literally up for interpretation but
in Java we have to do something a bit
differently something a bit different
actually have to construct an integer
how do these bytes so to do that it's
very simple all we have to do is go
through each of these we know that the
first byte he'll bring back our little
thing here whoops we know that the first
byte here is actually the most
significant byte okay which means that
it kind of belongs it needs to if if we
were to combine these we would get
something like this right since this is
the least significant binders is the
most significant byte this is kind of if
if you go back to the video where we
talked about bit shifting and whatnot we
need to kind of shift this all the way
up because if we were to kind of mask
this you know that we would get
something like this right and by mask
this I just mean if we were to set if we
were to try and separate this it would
be followed by a bunch of zeros not
actually missing one because it it is
kind of the most significant PI right
well that really means in practice is
that when we actually get that we don't
need a mask it by anything all we really
need to do is read source pointer so the
first byte that we read is the most
significant byte right big endian if we
read this one we do read it we just need
to kind of move it up 24 places 24
places because three bytes and three
bytes times eight add bits to make by it
3 times 8 is 24 ok and then we just need
to order all that with a source point of
plus one shifted 16 and then or it again
with source point two plus two eight and
then finally ordered with sauce pointer
plus three okay and then finally we need
to cast that entire thing into an
integer all right and I might just kind
of group these just two just so we know
the order of operations here and I'm
actually not sure what the what it will
choose to do but anyway once we've got
that we can just return that and there
you go that's a very long line of code
but that's essentially how we read an
integer from bunch of from a bunch of
bytes okay
so just as this just to test this out
real quick what we'll do is we'll write
out an integer so such as 505 let's see
what that is in binary
so it's this these four we'll take these
four we'll make a byte array called
bytes we will have commas there's our
byte array and then we'll do something
that will change this to say read int by
it's zero and then we'll just kind of
print that I think I don't get rid of
that all right yeah this is a really big
problem actually because see this is why
I'm not a big fan of Java because
unfortunately Java the bytes in Java are
actually signed which means that they go
from negative 128 to positive 127
instead of an unsigned byte which would
go from 0 to 255 which is typically how
you would represent things so honestly I
don't even know what to do in this case
because when you read it from a file
that will kind of sort itself out
naturally but I mean we cost that to
bite that probably just won't work we'll
see what happens
yeah we got negative seven great so
that's a bad example let's try something
different
let's and it probably is a way to do it
I just
what it is because I'm again I'm not
real I don't really do this stuff in
Java ever but we'll do something like
we'll write a bite into into data core
maybe like so 500 that was let's do
something like I don't okay let's do
like a thousand that should be kind of
reasonable bytes
okay so let's print that kind of comment
that out for now if we print that we'll
get okay eh that's way too high again
most of these are actually gonna be a
bit too high I'm gonna kind of try and
get let's see DS you're just shooting in
the dirt just blindly shooting here DC
that's too high
okay you know what let's keep it simple
let's write out 100 we handed that 64
this is actually just not decision this
is just kind of really boring because um
okay that will work so back here we go
apologies for the flailing as I'll
follow it but um okay so now we've got
this bite thing that we want to read out
into an integer and if we were to read
it we should get the value of like 10000
or whatever we entered then okay there
we go 10,000 so radiant clearly works
properly and that is all we wanted to
really test okay read short of course is
going to be kind of the same thing it's
going to return a short oops and it's
kind of gonna do the same thing except
we're gonna we're going to cut the first
two out of them it was just that and
that so nerve offset there and an offset
of 1 for the end read byte we don't
really need this but we'll have it
anyway just for the sake of having a
complete API I guess and then this will
literally just be returned sauce pointer
again you don't really need this
probably that silly to do it this way
but why not
we'll have char as well again Charles
going to work exactly the same way as
this in fact it is literally the same
thing we're just changing the type okay
done
now the long is of course just going to
be the end
except twice as long so read long long
this is actually just a bit annoying
really but let's take this whole thing
turn into the long first of all and add
one of these I'll actually just drop
this down a line because it's way too
long so plus 1 plus 3 plus 3 this will
be plus 4 plus 5 plus 6 and plus 7
okay we'll change this to be 60 yeah
that's correct
so 60 52 no wait what am I talking about
56 so 64 bits is long so it is easy 4
minus 8 is 56 48 some reason for the 6
instead of anyway
48:40 32 30 and I've made a mistake
somewhere what if I done now that seems
right 24:16 clearly I've made a mistake
so my day what have I done
1 2 3 Y Z so Nate what have I done oh ok
well firstly for that secondly
I'm actually just really confused right
now it's just not adding up Oh 30
cheering then to 30 well look at that
aren't I just the smartest person in the
world sixteen eight and then zero okay I
don't know what I did that or how I did
that but anyway that's not the point
um long day long day get it yeah see I
can still be funny anyway all that aside
that's how you read along okay
finally we have the flirt and the we've
got three things left right with the
float we've got the double and we've got
equal in so sauce and you can kind of
probably figure this the rest out myself
but of course I'm going to show you
anyway because I'm cool like that so
here we just need to basically do the
opposite which was flourish dot int bits
to float okay we take in we essentially
read the interest again a bit wasteful I
wonder if there's a way just to read it
straight from binary what we have here
the where the constructors so string
yeah
okay so there's really no yeah okay
doesn't matter if anyone knows let me
know I'm not gonna spend too much time
on this but we can just read an int of
course being source pointer and then
cast that to a float and then rip just
return that so it's actually quite easy
double will kind of be the same and not
really cost it to a float just just
called a float in bits to float thing
redouble so if possible chances to be
read long will change this to be double
dot long bits to double and we're done
okay and then finally for boolean's as
you can probably imagine static bullying
read bullying fight source int pointer
all we have to do is basically return
source pointer if it's one we'll just
return well yeah we can just return that
the problem with this is that if it's
anything but one it will be false
which is also kind of wrong so typically
in the kind of bullying way of things
you would return something like that
doesn't equal zero instead okay and in
that well that will kind of you kind of
call that your your bullying okay you
could always add an assertion here that
says something like source pointer
equals zero or source point equals one
okay which is make sure that it's at a
zero one but in general you know the way
that bullying is behaving something like
C and C++ is of course any non value any
nonzero value is kind of considered true
okay so there you go anyway that's
pretty much it this is pretty good we've
established a very good foundation
because we now have the ability to write
out everything okay any kind of data
that comes our way including even
strings we can just straight up just
write out which is awesome okay and you
might think but hang on what about a
raise but arrays are okay because arrays
will just be a bunch of like for example
if we had an integer array all that
would be is a bunch of right byte int
right so that's a bunch of calls to this
essentially with some kind of header
which says how long the array is and all
that stuff so it's really simple okay
now of course these headers need to be
structured in some way which we'll talk
about next time but we'll also talk
about specifically next time we'll talk
about our different types and how we can
actually be alike hey the data that will
follow is an integer because when we're
reading we obviously need to be like hey
which one of these do I call to guess my
appropriate thing okay but there we go
that's the complete kind of complete
salvation writer class which has all of
our static write and rate write and read
methods completed which is awesome okay
if you enjoyed this video you can
support me on
become 4/2 churner hit like button if
you liked the video and of course
slacked off the channel calm is the
awesome place to hang out for real-time
messaging with people just like you good
bye